l'allemagne l'italie la belgique le
luxembourg l'irlande et la finlande
fermé leur espace aérien aux compagnies
russes les avions russes ne peuvent plus
survolé ces pays la france vient
également de l'annoncé en début d'après
midi qui ferment aussi son espace aérien
à partir de ce soir annonce du ministre
délégué aux transports jean baptiste
djebbari on retrouve gérard feldzer
consultants en aéronautique ancien
pilote de ligne et président d'aviation
sans frontières bonjour cette décision
allait importante mais en quoi cela gêne
président russe vladimir poutine bref l
isolement il ya deux choses en fait ya
l'interdiction le survol qui est
interdit aux ruisseaux compagnie
aérienne rejette et y compris les vols
privés et puis lé droit de trafic là
c'est plutôt commerciale donc
l'isolément delà de la russie est
impacté par une espèce de cohésion à
auquel il s'attendait pas des tous les
pays européens parce que pratiquement
tous les pays européens ferment leurs
avions fermé leur leur espace aérien aux
russes et donc il va y avoir des
conséquences alors les conséquences pour
les russes ont dit connaissent et
d'isolement mais aussi sa faveur des
conséquences pour les compagnies et pour
les finances de l'europe puisque il va y
avoir l'interdiction de survol du
territoire russe alors déjà ukrainien
pour des mesures de sécurité on a déjà
lu avec malaisien en 2014 mais aussi ça
va obliger à faire des détours des
détours par le pôle nord quand il
s'agissait de faire un pari corée ou à
paris japon par exemple et donc ces
détournements si j'ose dire où ses
déroutes mans et ben ça coûte de
l'argent parce qu'un avion long courrier
c'est entre 200 et 300 euros la minute
et quand on met une heure ou deux heures
ou même trois heures de plus eh bien
c'est fini par chiffrer et plombé les
compagnies sans oublier que le prix du
pétrole augmente avec aussi alimenté par
le conflit donc on a des conséquences il
va falloir distribué peut-être en europe
les dommages collatéraux dans les
dommages collatéraux on reconnaît bien
c'est le tourisme russe qui va manquer
c'est en gros un milliard d'euros quand
même entre les stations de sports
d'hiver et la côte d'azur donc il ya des
conséquences pour les russes mais aussi
en conséquence pour les européens eux
mêmes et skipper des conséquences
militaires pour les russes est également
je pense à à l'approvisionnement avec
les avions cargo
alors oui le tout les tous les vols sont
réquisitionnés donc
les grosses compagnies ont le même sort
que cargo j'entends le même sort que les
compagnies régulières ils sont interdits
de survol c'est ça s'applique à tout le
monde bien évidemment donc là aussi on
va rallonger les routes et on va en ce
qui concerne l'asie qui représentent
quand même pas loin d'un tiers du trafic
mondial il va y avoir forcément un
impact donc entre la france si on prend
que la france et l'asie chine japon
corée du sud c'est 4 millions de
passagers pour les 20 pays d'europe du
nord qui sont concernés qui vont devoir
dérouter voire annuler leur vol par
ailleurs vladimir poutine là il garde
toujours la maîtrise du ciel ukrainien
alors pour l'envoi d'armes à l'ukraine
par les européens comment vont-elles
être acheminés par voie terrestre c'est
quand même risqué oui bien sûr la
question qui se pose sur les couloirs
aériens qui seront menacés
le terrestre qu'ils devront avoir
plusieurs solutions pour pouvoir
pénétrer dans le pays d'un côté ou un
autre donc effectivement c'est un
problème de logistique militaire qui est
engagée merci beaucoup gérard feldzer
pour vos informations et vos précisions
merci d'avoir est avec nous sur france